Uh
so today
the topic is
zero-sum games.
And what does this mean? A zero-sum game
is a game that features
exact conflict of interest.
So maybe I'll call it a
complete conflict of interest.
Another way of saying this is that one
player's gain
is the other player's loss.
And whenever I'm talking about losses
and gains, remember this is about
utilities, not about money. So it could
be about money if we're risk-neutral,
but more specifically
one player's utility gain is the other
player's utility loss.
So what are some examples where this is
a realistic assumption? Um a lot of
these examples are actually
>> [applause]
>> more parlor games, games like chess and
checkers.
So if we think about say chess
or checkers,
what happens? Well, assuming that people
only care about the winner of the game,
right? You could imagine someone who
just loves playing chess and they want
the game to last as long as possible or
they want a a beautiful game of chess,
but we're thinking about people who just
care about winning and losing. Well,
what are the possible outcomes? Well,
either player one wins
and if player one wins, we'll think of
the payoffs as being
one and negative one. One for the winner
and negative one for the loser, player
two.
The other option is player two wins
and then of course the payoffs are the
other way.
Negative one for player one who lost and
one for player two who won.
Uh and then the last possible outcome is
a draw,
a tie, and in that case we'll say the
payoffs are zero zero.
So here you can see that the players'
interests are exactly opposed, right? In
order for one player's payoff to go up,
the other player's payoff has to go
down.
And in this case the sum of the players'
payoffs is always zero.
So we see that payoffs
sum to zero.
Another common example of this would be
I should start in the middle.
games with monetary trade or monetary
exchange, so maybe money exchange.
But there we have to be careful. If
we're playing if we're bargaining about
how much money I give to you or how much
money you give to me, this can still be
a zero-sum game, but we need two
assumptions. So I'll say under two
conditions.
Well, the first condition
is that no money enters or leaves the
game, right? If we're negotiating and
then someone's parents come along and
give us both money, that's not a
zero-sum game anymore. So there's no
money in or out.
And then what's the second assumption we
need in order for this to actually be
a zero-sum game?
Thoughts?
Well, it's important that we're
risk-neutral.
Right? Because if we were risk-averse
for instance and the the terms of our
trade were that we're going to flip a
coin and someone's going to win a lot of
money and someone's going to lose a lot
of money,
well, if we're both risk-averse, that
that bet might be bad for both of us in
expected utility, right? Because we both
have a chance of losing a lot of money.
So the fact that no money comes in or
out doesn't necessarily mean that no
utility comes in or out unless we make
the further assumption that players are
risk-neutral.
But under these two assumptions, money
exchange is also going to be uh an
example.
Now, today we're kind of going backwards
historically. So zero-sum games were
some of the first games that were
studied in game theory. They were
studied by mathematicians who were
motivated by situations like chess and
checkers.
Subsequently, economists started getting
interested in game theory and then a lot
of economic situations outside of games,
outside of parlor games, the situation
is not zero-sum. And you often hear
people in politics talking about this
saying this is not a zero-sum game,
there's some arrangement we can make
that makes us both better off. So I'll
say maybe in the real world
things are often not zero-sum.
Maybe I'll say rarely zero-sum.
And that's why game theory has moved on
a bit beyond zero-sum games and looked
at things like Nash equilibrium that can
capture non-zero-sum games. But
mathematically, zero-sum games have a
very nice elegant theory. Uh so we're
going to cover it today and it does
apply to a lot of games uh like chess
and checkers and poker that, you know,
are relevant to some people.
Uh yes, question.
Yeah, so so formally risk-neutral means
that your von Neumann-Morgenstern
utility function as a function of money
is a linear function.
Um
so that you are indifferent between say
getting $10 for sure and a lottery that
pays you zero with probability half and
20 with probability half.
Good question. Any other questions? So
I'll say over money maybe to be
more clear.
Uh question or no?
Okay.
All right. So in the real world rarely
zero-sum, but maybe I'll say something
positive, but the theory is uh
elegant.
And if you play poker and you play these
games, it can often be a valuable
benchmark for some situations in the
real world that are close to strictly
competitive, close to complete conflict
of interest.
All right. So let's now formally define
what we mean by a zero-sum game.
So throughout today when we talk about
zero-sum games, we're always going to be
focusing on finite
two-player
strategic form games.
Uh finiteness is kind of a technical
assumption. A lot of the results extend
beyond finiteness.
Two player is really essential.
Uh games that only have two players with
opposed interests behave quite
differently than games that have more
than two players. So this is really
essential assumption.
And then the fact that we focus on
strategic forms is just a modeling
choice, right? A lot of games like chess
and checkers take place over time
and we would naturally model them in the
extensive form, but remember starting
with the extensive form, we can always
represent that game in the strategic
form and we're going to assume that
we've already done that transformation.
So how do we represent these games?
Well, we have two payoff functions,
player one's payoff
and player two's payoff. So let's just
remember, player one's payoff depends on
the strategy that player one chooses and
the strategy that player two chooses.
And similarly, player two's payoff
depends on both players' strategies. So
this is just a two-player game.
What makes it zero-sum?
Well, it's what you would think. The sum
of the payoffs is zero.
So this is zero-sum.
What does this mean?
It means that
player one's payoff
from some strategy profile S
plus player two's payoff
from the same strategy profile S is zero
for every strategy profile S.
And remember, this is a strategy
profile, so this is something like S1
S2.
So when I write it down, it looks like
just one equation, but really we have
many equations, right? We have a
separate equation that must hold for any
pair of strategies that the players
play.
And now we're going to make a
simplification.
If this is the case, then we can just do
a little algebra
and we see that that means that U2 of S
is equal to negative U1 of S
for every strategy profile S.
The payoff or utility that player two
gets is just negative of the utility
that player one gets.
And what that means is that if we're in
a zero-sum context,
we don't really have two utility
functions.
We really only have one function and
that determines what the other person's
utility is. Because once we know one
player's utility,
we know that the other player's utility
must always be the negative of that.
So we're going to adopt a convention.
So here's our convention for zero-sum
games.
We're basically only going to work with
player one's payoff.
So let's let
U = U1.
That's going to be player one's payoff
and that means we have in mind that U2
is equal to negative U.
But we're only going to keep track of
this single function U. So we're going
to focus on player one
and this means that U is going to
represent
player one's gain,
but it will also represent player two's
loss. Because a high value of U
means
a large negative value for player two,
which is a loss. So this represents
player two's gain.
So instead of thinking of each player uh
loss. Thank you.
So instead of thinking of each player as
having their own utility function that
they're trying to maximize,
we now just have one util- one function
U, but now the players are doing
different things with it. So, player one
is trying to maximize U,
but player two is trying to minimize U.
And we're going to maintain this uh
throughout the course. Now, this creates
this kind of asymmetry between the
players. Player is the maximizer, player
two is the minimizer.
I find that zero-sum games, it's really
easy to get yourself confused, so
hopefully I won't get confused today. I
don't think what we're doing today is
the hardest material we're going to
cover in the course, but I think it
probably is the most confusing. It's the
easiest uh lecture to get confused on.
So, if you have a question, please do
ask, and hopefully I won't confuse
myself with all these mins and maxes.
Okay.
So, that's going to be
our convention. And now let's just go
over one really simple example of a
zero-sum game to try to get our bearings
here.
And the classic zero-sum game uh would
be rock, paper, scissors.
So, let's look at this.
Now, we're going to represent this in
strategic form. So, we're going to have,
you know, a matrix here. Player one can
choose rock, paper, or scissors, and
player two can choose rock, paper, or
scissors.
Now, in the past when we represented a
strategic form game, every box in this
matrix had two numbers.
It had the payoff for player one and the
payoff for player two.
But now we're going to follow our
convention, and we're only going to put
one number in every box.
But that one number is going to
represent the gain for player one
and the loss for player two.
So, let's just fill this in
uh
cleverly. Well, if we go down the
diagonal,
in this case, everyone the two players
are making the same move, and that means
the game ends in a tie.
So, if the game ends in a tie, we'll say
the payoff is zero to both players. So,
along the diagonal we have zero, zero,
and zero.
Now, we want to put a one, remember this
is player one's payoff, whenever player
one wins the game. So, hopefully people
remember the rules for rock, paper,
scissors. Let's see. So,
um
scissors beat paper for player one, so
we have a one here.
Paper beats rock,
so we have a one here.
And rock beats scissors,
And in the other three spots, the winner
is player two, which means the payoff to
player one is negative one, cuz player
one is the loser. So, if player one
plays scissors and player two plays
rock, player one loses. Similarly,
player one loses, player one loses.
So, whenever we're talking about
zero-sum games, you're going to see
something like this. You're only going
to have a single number in every box,
rather than two numbers, but we're still
completely specifying the game because
of our uh assumption that that it's a
zero-sum game.
All right. So, now the question is, how
should someone play in this?
Um maybe how to play.
I think people probably know what's a
good strategy in rock, paper, scissors,
but let's kind of think it through.
One way to think it through is let's
take the perspective of player one.
And one thing player one could kind of
think about is they could say, "If I
choose a particular move or a particular
strategy,
what's the worst that can happen?"
Let me say,
what's
worst that can happen?
This is a very pessimistic or
conservative way of playing, but it's
it's one thing we can think about. So,
let's say I play rock, and I'm player
one.
What's the worst thing that can happen?
Well, player two could play
paper,
and they would beat me, right? So, the
worst thing, I'll put an arrow here, the
worst thing is
player two
plays paper,
and my payoff therefore is negative one.
And I'll just
negative one is my payoff.
Similarly, if I play paper, again the
worst thing is pretty bad. If I play
paper, then my opponent could play
scissors.
So,
and then again my payoff
is negative one.
And symmetrically, if I play scissors,
my opponent could play rock, and I could
get a payoff of negative one.
So, if I'm worried about the worst thing
that can happen,
and I only look at these pure
strategies, it looks pretty dire.
Whatever move I make, the worst thing
that can happen is the other player
plays the one move that beats me, I
lose, and therefore I get a payoff of
negative one.
But what if I instead strategy? Is there
any mixed strategy that I could play
that would ensure that even in the worst
case, I do pretty well?
Any thoughts? Uh yeah. They randomize so
that you play each of rock, paper,
scissors with one third
Great. So, let's look at the mixed
strategy. I'll write it down here, and
I'll call this strategy 1/3
1/3, 1/3.
And the meaning of this is I play rock
with probability 1/3, paper with
probability 1/3, and scissors with
probability 1/3.
And it's not too hard to see that if I
play this strategy, then whatever my
opponent does,
I'm going to win a third of the time,
I'm going to lose a third of the time,
and I'm going to tie a third of the
time. And therefore my expected payoff
is going to be zero. So, if I fill in
with this row what my payoff is when I
as player one use this mixed strategy,
and my opponent uses each of these
strategies, we're going to get zero,
zero, zero.
And the mathematical way to do this is
we're literally taking a third of this
row
plus a third of this row plus a third of
this row, and when we add those rows
together, we're just going to get zero
at the bottom.
So, here,
what's the worst case? The worst thing
that can happen? Well, actually in this
case it doesn't really matter what my
opponent does. Whatever my opponent
does, I get a payoff of zero.
So, this suggests and and we can if we
were careful went through it, we could
see that no other strategy is going to
do better in the worst case, right?
There's going to be no strategy in rock,
paper, scissors that ensures that I
always get a positive payoff. So, this
is actually going to do be a very good
strategy if I'm concerned uh
about the worst thing that can happen.
And I don't think it's really obvious
why I should be worried about the worst
thing that can happen. I mean, it's
reasonable, but there are other
reasonable things I can do. But
I promise you that it's going to turn
out that this turns out to be uh a very
useful and powerful way to play. So,
we're going to introduce some formal
terminology about this kind of reasoning
with the promise that later on it will
uh it will be very fruitful.
So, let's think about this worst case
or
reasoning.
So, let's formally think about what is
maybe I'll call this worst case
reasoning.
Another way of thinking about this is
maybe safe or conservative
or secure play.
Right? What I want is I want to find a
way to play in the games that whatever
my opponent does,
I'm guaranteed to do pretty well.
So, I'm interested in what payoff I can
guarantee even in the worst case, no
matter what my opponent does.
So, let's introduce this idea formally
in a more general case beyond rock,
paper, scissors.
So,
we'll think about player one.
So, for player one, they're looking at
gains.
Let me put player one here.
We have player two here.
So, when player one thinks about the
worst case that can happen, they're
saying, "What is the worst gain I can
get
as a function of my strategy
sigma one?"
Now, mathematically, this is just
saying, "Well,
the worst thing that can happen is that
my opponent plays a strategy that makes
my gain
as small as possible."
So, the worst case, I'm going to take a
minimum
over
sigma two.
Maybe I'll put
Remember our notation here that capital
sigma is the set of mixed strategies for
player two.
And I'll write U of
sigma one
sigma two.
So, let's think through this really
carefully. We're saying, "I'm player
one.
Suppose I use the mixed strategy sigma
What is the worst thing that can
happen?"
Well, the payoff I get is going to
depend on the strategy sigma two that my
opponent plays,
but I'm going to evaluate a minimum to
think of the worst thing that could
possibly happen, and I'm going to call
that my worst gain, WG, worst gain from
sigma one.
And gain reflects the fact that for me,
U, the payoff is a gain for me. It's a
good thing for me.
One observation here that we often make
is that I don't actually have to
minimize over all mixed strategies. If I
just minimize over pure strategies, I'd
get the same answer. So, we could also
write this as the min
over S2 in S2
of U of
sigma one, S2.
And the reason is that my payoff from a
mix if my opponent plays a mixed
strategy is just the average an average
over the payoffs I get if my opponent
plays pure strategies. So, the the worst
thing that can happen uh can will always
actually be a pure strategy, or there
will be a pure strategy that's worst.
And now let's do things symmetrically
for player two, okay? We want to do
think about this secure worst case
reasoning for player two, but now player
two is focused on their loss. So, I'm
going to call this WL of sigma two.
Because remember, these numbers in the
matrix for player two correspond to
losses to player two. So, I want to say,
"If I'm player two,
and I choose a mixed strategy sigma two,
what is the worst possible thing that
can happen?" The worst thing that can
happen is if my loss is as large as
possible.
So, I'm now going to write here a
maximum
over sigma one in sigma one
of U sigma one sigma two.
This says,
"How much I lose depends on what player
one does, and the worst possible loss is
if player one chooses the strategy that
makes my loss as large as possible." So,
we have a maximum here and a minimum
here.
And again,
this is the same as max
over S1 in S1.
Sigma two.
And we might call this my
worst
loss.
So, just to check our understanding, if
we went back to this example, if I'm
player one,
if I played sigma one equals R, what
would be my worst gain from R
in this game over here?
It would be negative one, right? Because
if I play R, the worst thing that can
happen is my opponent plays paper,
and then I lose, and I get a payoff of
negative one.
On the other hand, the worst gain from
the mixed strategy a third a third a
third is going to be zero. That's what
we showed uh down here.
And similarly for player two,
the worst loss, and maybe since we
haven't worked with player two much,
let's be careful. The worst loss for
player two if they play R in this game
would be what? Let's say I'm player two,
and I play rock in rock, paper,
scissors, what is my worst loss?
So, we have to be careful here. It's
It's It's actually one, right? You might
be tempted to say negative one, but
remember, this is how much I'm losing,
right? So, the worst case for me, if I'm
player two,
and I play R,
well, I'm trying to minimize how much I
lose, so the worst loss is if my
opponent plays paper, and I lose utility
one. My loss is one.
Uh
so, just keep this in mind, and this is
why things can be a little bit uh
confusing here. Yes? Um I understand
that structurally why mixed strategy is
the same as pure strategy for those
formulations that you have there. I want
to confirm, does this just hold for this
game, or is that a more general result
for zero-sum games?
Uh so, it's actually It's a very general
result that
once I fix one player's strategy
uh in a two-player game,
and now I want to maximize the payoff
of the other player, or minimize the
payoff of the other player, that maximum
or minimum will be achieved by a pure
strategy.
More generally, in an N-player game, if
I fix the strategies of all but one of
the players, N minus one of the players,
and now I contemplate uh a choice of
strategy for that last player, that
payoff will be maximized or minimized by
a pure strategy. Maybe also by a mixed
strategy, but in particular by a pure
strategy. But, we have to be really
careful here.
Uh
On the other hand, it's not true that
if I take a step back and look at the
worst-case gain, that my best worst-case
gain can be achieved by a pure strategy.
That's not true, and that's exactly what
we saw over here. Because if I
restricted myself to a pure strategy,
then my worst-case gain was always
negative one. And it was very important
that we allowed myself to use mixed
strategies. So, mathematically, what's
going on
is that once I fix one player's
strategy,
the utility function as a function of
the other player's strategy is a linear
function.
And a linear function over probabilities
achieves its maximum at at a corner
solution at the endpoints.
But, the worst-case gain function WG is
no longer a linear function.
Because it's a minimum over linear
functions, it's actually going to be a
concave function. Uh and that's
mathematically what's going on.
Good question. Any other questions on
this?
All right.
So, we've
defined we've thought through worst-case
reasoning.
And now we want to go a step further and
talk about something called security
strategies, which just formalizes what
we talked about in this game before.
So, what is a security strategy? Well,
when I'm choosing what strategy to play
as player one, I evaluate each strategy
according to its worst-case payoff, and
I choose the strategy that maximizes
that worst-case payoff.
So, for player one,
we say
a strategy sigma one star is a security
strategy
if
the worst-case gain from sigma one star
is better than the worst-case gain I
would get from any alternative strategy.
So, I'm comparing,
if I use strategy sigma one star, what
is the worst-case gain I get?
If I use a different strategy sigma one,
what is the worst-case gain that I get?
And I would like the worst-case gain to
be as large as possible. And that's what
it means to be a security strategy.
And then for player two, things are just
symmetric.
For player two, we say sigma two star
is a security strategy, I'll just say
SS,
if
let's be careful here. Now, we're
worried about the worst-case loss
of sigma two star
And for player two, they're minimizing,
they care about losses, so sigma two
star is best for them if the loss is as
small as possible. Right? So, they want
the worst-case loss from sigma two star
to be less than or equal to
the worst-case loss from sigma two
for all
sigma two in
sigma two.
And here, going back to the question
over here,
uh it is really important that we that
we contemplate mixed strategies uh here.
We can't just look at pure strategies.
Okay.
Let's We have this definition.
So, it's nice to have
um
some notation here. If we think about
player one, come back to this.
So, now that we have this notion of
security strategies, we can start
thinking about payoffs.
So, maybe I'll we'll start thinking
about secure payoffs.
And what we want to give a name to is
what is this
best worst-case gain for player one?
So,
for player one,
let's look at this quantity.
It's often helpful. We'll call it V
lower bar for reasons that will become
clear.
is the max
over sigma one
of WG of sigma one.
So, we think of this as
the gain,
the best gain
that player one can secure.
So, if we go back to our definition over
here, if player one plays a security
strategy,
then their worst-case gain from that
security strategy will precisely be V
lower bar.
If they chose a non-security strategy,
the worst-case gain would be strictly
smaller.
But, under a security strategy, the
worst-case gain is exactly equal to V
lower bar.
So, one way of saying of defining a
security strategy is precisely that the
worst-case gain is equal to the maximum
possible worst-case gain.
And then we can also define for player
two
what we might call V upper bar,
and that is going to be the minimum over
sigma two
of the worst-case loss
of
sigma two.
So, maybe it this is the best
worst-case loss
or the best loss
that P2 can secure.
So, what this says is, "Suppose player
two plays a security strategy.
They know that however their opponent
plays,
their uh loss is going to be no worse
than V upper bar."
And player one knows that if they play a
security strategy, their gain is going
to be no worse than V lower bar. They're
always going to get at least V lower
bar.
And now we can see it starts to get a
little confusing as we look at the min
of the max.
But
what we'd like to understand
is the relationship between these two
numbers.
So, the gain that player one can secure
and the loss that player two can secure.
Uh and
Let's uh
Let's go down here and try to think
about this. So, the first question we
want to understand
is what is the relationship between V
lower bar and V upper bar?
Well, the way I have to find them kind
of makes it clear. V upper bar is going
to be bigger than V lower bar, but let's
try to understand why. Okay? What we
want to argue
is that V lower bar
must be smaller than V upper bar.
Um
And
Say it again? Is that strict?
Uh we'll we'll we'll see later. It will
not be strict, but uh there's going to
be a weak inequality.
Uh and I think the way I one way I like
to try to think about this is with a
little graph here. Well, let's think of
P1 and P2.
And
in the end these will be equal, but
let's let's not draw it this way.
Uh
What does V lower bar mean for player
one? Let's think about how to interpret
it. It means player one can play a
security strategy.
And if player one plays a security
strategy, however the other player pay
plays, their payoff is at least V lower
bar.
So, what my security strategy tells me,
this gets to the idea of a guarantee. It
says if I'm player one and I play my
security strategy, I don't know how my
opponent will play.
But however they play, my payoff is
going to be somewhere in here. It's
going to be at least V lower bar.
And the fact that I'm choosing a
security strategy means there's no way I
can make this graph any better. I
couldn't choose another strategy that
would ensure that my payoff were
strictly higher than this.
And similarly for V upper bar, what it
tells me is if player two
plays their security strategy,
it tells me that their loss is always
smaller than V upper bar.
So, they don't know exactly how much
they're going to lose. It depends on
what the other player does. But however
the other player plays, they're never
going to lose more than V upper bar.
Now, this is a bit of a misleading
diagram cuz in the end these we're going
to show these two numbers are equal, but
I think this kind of illustrates um
what goes on.
Now,
how can we show this inequality?
What we want to understand is what would
happen if each player played their
security strategy. So, I want to give
kind of a graphical argument and then
we'll give the mathematical argument.
But intuitively, suppose we both play
our security strategies.
Or both play a security strategy. We may
have multiple security strategies. What
if both play
security strategies?
Well, what's going to happen to player
one's payoff?
They're playing one of their security
strategies, so the gain they get has to
be somewhere in here.
But now player two is also playing their
security strategy, so the loss they
experience must be somewhere in here.
But
they're playing these strategies,
there's some actual gain and actual
loss. So, what it tells us is we must be
somewhere in this box if we both play
our security strategies.
And let's try to show that
uh mathematically.
So, let's look at what happens.
So, here's the result. For any
security strategies
sigma one star
and sigma two star,
let's try to understand what is the
payoff
U1 star U2 star.
So, player one's playing their security
strategy.
Player two's playing their security
strategy and we want to understand U,
which is the gain for player one and the
loss for player two. Right?
Well,
what do we know about this?
We exactly want to go through
this reasoning here.
Well, the loss, this is the loss for
player two.
So, this loss can't be any worse than
player two's worst loss from playing
sigma two star.
So, this must be less than or equal to
the
worst loss of sigma two star. Why? Well,
this is just the definition, right?
This says if I play sigma two star,
however my opponent plays, my loss is
smaller than the worst loss.
In particular, if my opponent plays
sigma one star, then my loss must be
smaller than my worst case loss.
Cuz the worst case loss is
as high as possible.
Then in the other direction,
we want to claim
this.
Well,
if I play sigma one star,
my worst case gain is WG of sigma one
star.
So, that says however my opponent plays,
I need to get it I'm going to get a
payoff of at least this.
So, in particular, if my opponent plays
sigma two star, my payoff is going to
have to be higher than this.
And this is
V lower bar
and this is V upper bar.
Notice here that these middle
inequalities didn't actually depend on
the fact that these were security
strategies. The middle inequalities just
followed from the definitions of worst
case loss and worst case gain. But the
outer equalities are using the fact that
sigma one star is a security strategy
for player one and sigma two star is a
security strategy for player two.
Um I think there's one last way of kind
of interpreting this that may be a bit
more reasonable, a bit more good easy to
interpret.
And we can think of this as what would
happen
if player one goes first
and their move is observed. And their
mixed strategy is observed.
Well, I claim that if player one goes
first and plays sigma one star,
the worst case gain is exactly what
would happen.
Why? Well, if I'm player one
and I go first and I choose sigma one
star and my opponent can see that, well,
my opponent and I have exactly
misaligned interests.
So, my opponent is going to try to
minimize my gain.
And that's exactly what the worst case
gain from sigma one star captures.
And if I anticipate that, I want to
choose the strategy that will do best
taking into account the fact that when I
do it, my opponent is going to uh
choose the strategy that makes me as as
worse off as possible.
And that's exactly what V lower bar
represents.
Similarly, V upper bar, we can think of
that as representing, well, if P2 moves
first
and their mixed strategy is observed.
Well, now it's the same reasoning,
right?
If I observably choose sigma two,
then my opponent player one is going to
try to make my loss as player two as
large as possible. They're exactly going
to induce my payoff of the worst case
loss.
Anticipating that, I want to try to make
this worst case loss as small as
possible by playing a security strategy
sigma two star.
So, the inequality we've shown here
captures a pretty intuitive idea that
moving first and having your move
observed is a weak disadvantage.
Player one does worse when they move
first and the other player gets to see
what they do, at least
weakly, than if player two moved first
and player one got to observe that
player two was Our interests are
opposed. If I get to see what you do,
that's really going to help me.
In general.
Or I can weakly help me.
Any questions on this? I feel like this
always
is quite confusing the first time you
see it. Any uh
any questions?
Now, I think a lot of people have this
intuition that moving first is a strict
advantage or is a strict disadvantage.
That if I have to move and the other
person gets to see what I'm doing, they
can kind of punish me and exploit me and
I'm not going to do very well. And the
surprising result that von Neumann
proved that we're now going to state is
that it actually doesn't matter who goes
first.
That these two values, the upper bar and
V lower bar, are actually equal.
And that's exactly uh the result we're
going to show.
So, this is a very famous theorem called
the minimax theorem.
And this is proven by von Neumann
in 1928. So, notice, you know, Nash's
theorem was proven in 1950. So, this
work on zero sum games came before Nash.
And so, Nash, people say is the the
founder of game theory, but really what
he did is extended game theory away from
zero sum games to non-zero sum games.
Zero sum game theory was actually
already understood uh when Nash came
along.
And the theorem is in any
finite
two player
zero sum game,
well, V lower bar
equals V upper bar.
And now let's just write out exactly
what that means. Okay? So, V lower bar
is the worst case gain of sigma one
star. So this is
the
max over sigma one.
Let's make sure this is what we mean to
say.
Let's look at each of these inner
things.
If player one plays sigma one
and player two chooses sigma two to
minimize player one's payoff, this is
the worst case gain for player one from
choosing sigma one. So this is exactly
WG
of sigma one.
And indeed, if we then maximize the
worst case gain over sigma one, this is
exactly the definition of V lower bar,
right?
And then on the other hand,
if I'm player two
and I'm playing sigma two
and my opponent chooses sigma one to
maximize my loss, this is my worst case
loss from playing sigma two.
And if I then minimize this over all
sigma two, that's exactly the upper bar
by definition, right?
Now,
the inequality from here to here is what
we already showed. That's what we showed
in class, that this is less than or
equal to this. The content of the
theorem is to say that in fact we have
equality. So this graph I showed up here
is wrong. In fact,
everything just collapses
right to here.
And let's go through how we interpret
this in terms of who goes first, right?
On the left-hand side, what we imagine
is player one moves first.
Their move is observed
and then player two, antic- seeing what
player one does, makes player one as
worse off as possible.
So this is the case where player one
moves observably first.
This represents what happens if player
two moves observably first.
And seeing player two's move, player one
then chooses what's optimal for player
one.
So what we said is that in general, we
would expect that moving first for
player one would be a disadvantage, and
indeed we showed that this is less than
or equal to this. What von Neumann tells
us is that
if we
play optimally, in fact it's not a
disadvantage at all. It's going to do
exactly as well as if uh the other
player moved first.
Um
Now, this common number here that's
equal to V lower bar and V upper bar, we
give it a name and we'll call this V,
right? It's a good name for something
that's equal to both V lower bar and V
upper bar. And this is called the value
of the game.
So let's try to understand what this
means and let's go through a few
uh examples.
So what is the value of a game?
We can think of it in a few ways.
What I think it does it captures
it's an objective measure
of the relative advantage of the two
players in this game.
So maybe I would say of the fairness
or
relative advantage
in the game.
So we have to kind of put ourselves in
the position uh before von Neumann's
theorem was proven. What people thought
is you had these games like chess and
checkers
and there's not really a way to say
who has an advantage. People would say,
"Well, does player one have advantage or
player two?" Well, it depends who's
better at the game.
That's what most people would have said.
There isn't some single objective number
that captures how much of advantage this
game has. Uh von Neumann's theorem tells
us that in fact, no, there is an
objective measure that tells us if
people play  or optimally,
who should win the game.
In other words, how much better player
one should do than player two if both
players play optimally. And this
captures how fair the game is for the
two players and or or more precisely,
quantifies the size of the advantage
that either player one or player two
has.
So one maybe, you know, at first you
might say, "Ah, we've just done some
inequalities, there's nothing fancy
here." But one amazing implication of
this is that chess has a value.
Chess either
In fact, we can say more, the value in
chess is actually either plus one
minus one or zero. Now, chess is uh
yeah, chess is still finite games, so
everything applies.
What this means is if the value of chess
is one,
that means that player one can guarantee
that they win in chess.
So then this uh who moves first in
chess? White? Should know this. Uh the
first player, right?
Negative one means
uh player two can guarantee that they
always win in chess, the player with the
black pieces.
And zero means each player can guarantee
a draw.
And von Neumann's theorem tells us that
chess has a value and in fact, if we're
a bit careful, it tells us that its
value must take one of these three
numbers.
But we don't know which number it is.
So but which ONE IS UNKNOWN?
HOW IS THIS UNKNOWN? I JUST WROTE IT
DOWN. YOU just have to do maxmin.
Why is this unknown?
I mean, I give you Here's the formula.
Just write it down, right?
The issue is that chess is extremely
complex.
So the set of strategies in chess is,
you know, bigger than the number of
atoms in the universe. So yeah, we could
just
try to solve this optimization problem,
but it would have, you know, an absurdly
large number of of variables, we
wouldn't be able to solve it.
Um but this I think shows us the power
of
von Neumann's theorem that it tells us
that in fact, chess has a value. It
either advantages one player or the
other, we just don't know what the value
is because we're not able to calculate
it cuz it's so complicated.
Um let's go through a few examples of
games to try to
understand this concept of a value. So
let's start with a game
let's say top bottom left right.
And let's
make this
1 1
-4 -8.
So
player one chooses top or bottom.
Player two chooses left or right. And
the question is what is the value in
this game? Or another way of saying this
is if you were going to play this game
and you were asked, "Do you want to be
player one or player two?"
Which player would you rather be?
Any
thoughts?
Yeah.
I'm not
sure which is one or two. Uh uh this is
player one and this is player two. I'd
rather be player two.
Should be one. Okay, and why?
Just cuz like if you look at all the
outcomes, like you're going
I don't really have Like if she did
these negative values, you could lose
that.
But I don't know, -4, -8, these are
pretty big negative numbers, right? So
if I just look at it,
I see some really big negative numbers.
You're right, but I I I'm not convinced.
You haven't convinced me yet.
But let's notice, if we just naively
looked at this game, we might say, "Oh,
this is a good game for player
uh two." Because remember, a big
negative number for player one means
player two's doing really, really well.
But
the structure of the game affects uh who
has advantage. Anyone else why who How
would they play? Uh maybe in the red
sweater? I don't think I've heard from
you. Yeah? Player one plays top and they
guarantee one.
Exactly. So even though we have some
really big negative numbers down here,
and notice this is still a zero-sum
game. I think people get confused and
say, "Oh, we have these really big
negative numbers." It's still zero-sum.
What this -4 means is player two wins
four if we come down here.
But because the structure of the game,
if I'm player one, my security strategy
here is T.
If I play T,
whatever my opponent does, I'm going to
get a payoff of one.
And if I were to play anything else
other than than T,
I wouldn't be able to secure a payoff of
one.
And in this case, it turns out player
two actually anything is a security
strategy for player two.
And what that So what we see in this
game is the value V is one.
Player one by playing T can secure a
payoff of one and there's no way they
can secure anything uh higher than that.
So I hopefully this makes it a bit more
concrete uh what these these numbers
mean. Let's do another example the
similar flavor.
Say
that's
a bad example.
Well, it doesn't really matter. We'll
make all the numbers positive. That's
fine. Uh let's look at this game.
What is the
value of
of this game or which player
I mean I guess here it's it's pretty
clear which player you'd rather be
because all the payoffs are positive.
So, I definitely want to be player one
here, but the question is what is the
value
of this game?
You think through it? Yeah. I think it'd
be -8. -8? Okay, I I don't think so, but
let's see. Let's Let's Let's think
through. So, So, why -8? It's the same
player two if he chooses right. He can
catch themselves.
Like a
Right, so it'd be it'd be positive. Do
we have to be This is where it gets
really confusing. So, player two is
trying to
uh
they want to minimize things.
Um
So, let's think through. If player So,
let's just walk through it, right? Let's
say player two plays R.
Then, they're either going to lose 23 or
lose eight. So, they would want to
choose L. So, they would want to choose
L. And if they choose L, well, whatever
the other player does, the loss to
player two is only one. So, playing L is
much better. So, it turns out in this
case L is going to be a security
strategy for player two.
And the value of the game is then going
to be one. Player one gets one and
player two loses one. So, here we see
the value is one.
Now, notice an implication of this. If
we looked at these two games, if you
just sort of at first stared at it, you
would probably say this game is so much
better for player one than this game is.
Cuz if I look at every cell of the game,
the payoff is at least as high in this
game.
And sometimes a lot higher. 23 is a lot
bigger or eight is a lot bigger than -8.
23 is a lot bigger than one. But, if I
know the min-max theorem actually tells
us no, each of these games has some
objective value that captures the
relative advantage of player one and
player two if people play optimally. And
in fact, these two games have exactly
the same value even though a lot of the
payoffs seem a lot higher in this game.
Now, would you really be indifferent
between these games? Well, it depends
who you're playing against, right? If
you're playing against a computer who's
really rational, probably. If you're
playing against a person who makes
mistakes, maybe you'd actually rather uh
play this game. Because when we
calculate the value of the game, there's
this implicit assumption that people are
behaving are very good at computing
things and are uh are playing
rationally.
Okay, final example.
What about this game? What is the
value of this game?
And what would the security strategies
be? Yeah.
It is. Yeah. And what are the What would
the security strategies be here?
Exactly. So, let's let's go through it.
So, here the value is zero. This is a
game we studied before. We just only put
in one number here. Let's say I'm player
one.
Let's try to compute my security
strategy. Well, if I play T, things
could go really badly cuz my opponent
could play R and I get -1.
If I play B, things could go really
badly. My opponent could play L and I
would get -1. But, if I mix 50/50, then
I ensure that I always get a payoff of
at least zero, in fact exactly zero. And
we can do similar reasoning for player
two and see that the value is zero and
in fact, each player has a unique
security strategy. So, security strategy
equals half half for each player.
I guess technically it's half T, half B
for player one and half L plus half R
for player two, so
I'm being a little
Great. Yes. Is it too general to say
that there's not a strictly dominant
strategy, then it's always going to be
zero? Um no, because
uh no, that's not going to be true. So,
I
uh in these actually in these cases, we
only have uh
weak dominance, not uh
strict dominance, right? Um
but in general, you can have much more
complicated games uh
where
So, we'll actually see an example later
today of a game uh with that property.
But, good good observation. Yeah.
In fact, one player could even have a
strictly dominant strategy and still
lose a lot, right? It could be that one
strategy is better than everything else,
but whatever I do, I I lose a lot of
money.
Um yeah. Any other questions?
Okay, so now we would like to connect
what we've done here to what we've been
doing throughout the course.
So,
I think it's important to understand
that before what we looked at was Nash
equilibrium.
And Nash equilibrium captured stability.
It said that if each player
is playing according to a Nash
equilibrium, then this out this this
strategy profile is stable in the sense
that no player can do strictly better by
unilaterally deviating.
Security strategies
capture something very different.
Security strategies, well, they capture
security or safety.
Each player is is just thinking, "How
can I play to ensure that whatever
happens, I do reasonably well?"
But, it turns out that there's a tight
connection between these and that's what
our next result is going to say.
It's going to say that in fact, in
zero-sum games,
these are basically the same concept.
That Nash equilibria and security
strategies coincide in zero-sum games.
So, let me be more precise about that.
So,
in as usual
any finite
two-player
zero-sum game,
Now, remember,
Nash equilibrium always makes sense.
Security strategies only make sense in
two-player zero-sum games. So, I we
can't It's not even meaningful to say do
these concepts coincide beyond zero-sum
games cuz this concept doesn't even make
sense. But, in any finite two-player
zero-sum game, at least both of these
concepts make sense.
And let's say for any strategy profile,
mixed strategy profile sigma one, sigma
two,
So, I'm I fix the game
and I consider an arbitrary strategy
profile sigma one, sigma two.
I'm going to argue that
sigma one, sigma two is a Nash
equilibrium
if and only if So, I'm saying two
statements are equivalent. One statement
is that this strategy profile is a Nash
equilibrium.
The other statement is that each
component of this profile is a security
strategy.
So, if and only if
sigma one
is a security strategy for player one
and sigma two
is a security strategy
for player two.
So, this is an if and only if statement.
So, let's make sure we understand both
directions. It says if if you give me a
strategy profile in a zero-sum game and
it is a Nash equilibrium, I can
immediately conclude that player one
strategy must be a security strategy for
player one
and player two strategy must be a
security strategy for player two.
Now, let's look at the other direction.
It says if I find a security strategy
sigma one for player one
and I find a security strategy sigma two
for player two and I now consider the
strategy profile containing these two
strategies, so player one plays his
security strategy, player two plays her
security strategy, then that strategy
profile is necessarily a Nash
equilibrium.
So, it connects these two ideas. It also
has an implication for computation.
Let's say you're asked on a problem set
or an exam to find a Nash equilibrium of
a zero-sum game. This theorem tells you
one way you could do it. How could you
do it?
That's it. You go to player one.
You solve for player one security
strategy. There may be more than one,
but you find one of them.
You go to player two. You solve for
player two security strategies. You find
one of them. You put those together.
Now, you have a Nash equilibrium.
Now, the nice story is that this is
computationally easier than finding Nash
equilibrium the other way.
That's true for computers. I find this
actually very rarely true on exams that
you're better off taking this approach,
but if you were a computer, you would
find that this would be a very good way
of of computing uh Nash equilibrium.
But, for humans, I don't know. Uh it's
hard to find a good example. But, in
principle, this gives uh
easy computation
of Nash equilibrium.
And what's amazing about it is that you
can compute the Nash equilibria by
separately finding a strategy for the
two players, right? Normally, Nash
equilibrium is about the interaction
between strategies. And what makes
finding it hard is what's best for one
player depends on what's best for the
what the other player does. But, this
says you can sort of separate this
computation into just two simple
optimization problems for the two
players and then you get a Nash
equilibrium. So, computationally uh
that's why it's very nice.
Okay, I want to try to show you the
argument for this. Uh it's very short,
but it is
going to have to be a little careful.
So, let's go through it.
So, let's first show
uh
this direction.
So, what I want to say is suppose I've
computed a security strategy for each
player.
So, let's say sigma one star
is a security strategy for P1
and sigma two star
is a security strategy for P2.
All right, I've done that. Now, what I
want to argue is that this pair, sigma
one star, sigma two star, is a Nash
equilibrium of the game. Okay?
And really, I just have to remember my
formula
over here.
So, let me
just uh
look at my formula from over there.
I want to look at
U of
sigma one star
sigma two star
and
I immediately know
that this is
Should I do it the other way?
Yeah, it doesn't matter which way we do
it.
Uh check. It might help. It might look
nicer if I do it the other way.
Hm.
Well, we'll we'll we'll start here.
Okay.
Now, up here we just had an inequality
between these statements.
But now, we have an equality because of
the minimax theorem. So, the minimax
theorem tells us that the worst case
loss from sigma two star must equal the
worst case gain from sigma one star, and
we have equality uh in this expression
from that last inequality.
And now, what we want to show is that we
have a Nash equilibrium.
Well,
let's look at what happens
if player two were to deviate.
Okay?
So,
this is what happens under our strategy
profile. Let's suppose that player two
deviates to some strategy sigma two
prime.
How does this relate
to the worst case gain
for player one?
What can we say about the relationship
between this and this?
Yeah. Worst case gain is obvious. It's
an inequality.
Uh
I think it's actually going to be
this way, right?
Let's make sure. So, it's always This is
always really confusing. The worst case
gain says, whatever my opponent does
I'm guaranteed to get a payoff of at
least the worst case gain.
So, one thing my opponent could do is
they could deviate to sigma two prime.
And if they chose sigma two prime, then
that's one thing they can do. It must be
at least as good as the worst thing they
can do for me as player one, right?
Okay, now let's try to get this last
one. What if player one were to deviate?
So, player one deviates, what's the
relationship between this
and the worst case loss for sigma two
star? You always This it's really easy
to get confused here.
It's actually going to be the same,
right?
Because this says
my Now, I'm taking the perspective of
player two.
If I play sigma two star as player two
the worst loss for me is this.
So, if player one plays sigma one prime,
that loss can't be as bad as the worst
loss
which means the loss is smaller.
Not as bad loss is a smaller loss.
So, here I just used
the definitions
of worst case loss, and here I'm
actually using the minimax theorem.
Because in general, we only have
inequalities here, but the minimax
theorem says they have to be equalities.
And now, I claim that we're done.
Someone look. Now, we just have to
squint.
Of course, this proof is pretty hard to
come up with, right? I've done it just
right, so it seems easy. It's I mean,
it's not it's not easy, right? Uh you
have to know exactly where you're going.
Um but
can someone just walk me through why
I've already shown that this is a Nash
equilibrium? If we just look really
carefully.
I always find this confusing, so uh
Yeah. I mean,
like if you look
U of that is player two doing worse, so
they don't want to Okay, so sorry. So,
you're left side or the right side?
Which side? You're on the left side,
okay? So, you're here. Yeah?
Okay.
This is player two deviating and then
doing
uh
No, this is player one doing This is
player one deviating. Let's make sure,
right? If we compare here, player two is
doing the same thing.
And player one, instead of doing what
they're supposed to do in equilibrium,
is deviating to sigma one prime. So,
player one's deviating, and what
happens?
They're doing weakly worse. So, this
says any deviation by player one is
unprofitable. Player one does weakly
worse by deviating from sigma one star
to sigma one prime, and crucially, this
is holding for all
sigma one prime
and sigma two prime.
Okay? So, what what we've shown what
you've argued verbally is that player
one cannot profitably deviate. However
they deviate, player one does weakly
worse.
What about the other case? What about
player two?
How does this show me that player two
can't profit? Yeah?
So, I'm going to write where player two
is deviating, right?
Yes, exactly. And player one
at least as bad or better, right?
They should Right, they don't have any
alternatives then.
Right. So, you have to be careful
though, cuz we're interested in how
player two is doing, right? So, so
player two was doing this. They deviate
to this. It looks like play player that
the payoff is higher. But we have to
think it's player two. So, what does
this mean? Player one's payoff is
higher, player two's is
lower or just Exactly right. So, this
says, if player two deviates from sigma
two star to sigma two prime this is
player two's loss. So, this says player
two's loss is weakly higher than their
loss in equilibrium
that means their deviation makes them
weakly worse off, and therefore, neither
player can benefit by deviating, and
therefore, we have a Nash equilibrium.
So, you just have to string the
inequalities together in just the right
way. I always think it's very easy to
get confused, but uh here we are.
Any questions on this?
So, now we want to show the reverse
direction.
We want to show
Let's start by saying suppose sigma one,
sigma two
uh
is a Nash equilibrium, we want to say
that both players must be playing
security strategies.
But we're actually going to
uh
erase this. We're actually going to
prove this by contradiction. So, we have
to be a little careful. What we're going
to say is to show that if it's an
equilibrium
both players must be playing security
strategies, we're going to show if some
player were not playing a security
strategy, then it could not be an
equilibrium.
So,
by symmetry, let's say suppose
sigma one is not a security strategy
for player one.
I want to show, WTS, want to show
that sigma one, sigma two
is not a Nash equilibrium.
So, this is my way of saying in any Nash
equilibrium, both players must be
playing security strategies. Because if
some player is not playing a security
strategy, then it couldn't have been a
Nash equilibrium.
Now, I'm saying what if sigma one is not
a security strategy, there's a symmetric
argument if sigma two is not a security
strategy.
So, one way of saying this is I can't
find an equilibrium where players are
not playing security strategies.
That's one way of saying this.
Okay? Uh and now, this one
again, it's short. The argument's really
short if you know exactly where you're
going. Uh but it's tricky. I need to
make sure I
get it right in my notes. So, what do we
know?
Let's look at sigma one, sigma two.
This is always what we look at.
And what's the relationship between this
and WG of sigma one?
Yeah. The equality sign goes this way.
Uh I think it's at least
Let's see. Maybe that's what you said.
Maybe I didn't hear you. Let's check.
This is the
If I play sigma one as player one this
is the worst that can happen to me as
player one. So, sigma two is one thing
player two could do. The one thing they
could do is at least as good for me as
the worst thing that can happen, so I
get this inequality, right?
Okay.
And because we have this
weak inequality, we're going to argue in
two separate cases. There's two
possibilities. Either this is strictly
bigger than this or it's equal. Okay?
So, let me actually write it down like
this.
Write it like this. So, what I'm saying
is there's two cases.
Maybe you can add a bit more detail on
your notes to make it clearer since I'm
sort of doing it dynamically, but we
know that this is weakly bigger than
this, so there's only two possibilities.
Either they're equal or one is strictly
bigger than the other. And I want to
show that in either case, we don't have
a Nash equilibrium. In either case,
someone has a profitable deviation.
Uh I think this one is actually
the easier direction.
So,
here I want to show that player one has
a profitable deviation.
Okay?
Using the fact that sigma one is not a
security strategy for player one. Can
anyone try to think through? I think
it's it's good to try to think through
it before you see it, otherwise there's
no way to remember, right? So, I want to
claim I want to argue that player one
can has a strictly profitable deviation
precisely because sigma one is not a
security strategy. Anyone think through?
How we might do that? Yeah?
Perhaps
you know the worst gain of sigma one
security strategy is going to be greater
than the worst case or the worst gain of
this current strategy that sigma one is
playing, which means that if we switch
to the security strategy we're getting a
certainly or weakly I guess
It's actually going to be strictly.
Yeah, so great great. So, exactly right.
Sigma one is not a security strategy.
So, let's consider a deviation to a
security strategy. What happens if
player one deviated to a security
strategy say sigma one star?
Okay?
So, I want to say instead of playing
sigma one, which we know is not a
security strategy,
let's say player one deviates to a
security strategy sigma one star.
And I want to show that player one does
strictly better.
How do I show it? Well,
because sigma one is not a security
strategy, the worst gain from sigma one
is strictly worse than the worst gain
from the security strategy.
This is what it means to be a security
strategy. It means sigma one star
maximizes the worst gain, whereas sigma
one does not.
Now, I'm almost done. Now, I just need
one more inequality here. How do we get
this
last inequality?
This is the same thing we've always been
using, right? But it's always hard to
remember.
If this is the worst that player one
does when they play sigma one star,
then if player two plays sigma two,
player one must do weakly better than
the worst thing.
And now if I tie these inequalities
together, what have I shown? I've shown
that player one can strictly benefit by
playing sigma one star. I only have a
weak inequality here, but I have a
strict inequality here. So, if I link
them all together, I've identified a
strictly profitable deviation for player
one. I'm saying if player one is not
playing a security strategy, they must
be able to profitably deviate to a
security strategy. Though, this relied
on this assumption here.
Now, let's go to
the other case.
So, here what I showed is that
player one has a profitable deviation.
So, any guesses about what I might show
here?
Yeah?
Player two has a profitable deviation,
right? So, I want to show that player
two has a profitable
deviation.
Hmm.
Any thoughts? How can I
Well, we actually just have to unpeel
the definition of the worst case gain.
Okay? [snorts]
What is this? Well, this is exactly the
minimum
over sigma two
of U of sigma one
sigma two.
And I claim we're already done. We just
have to look at it really carefully.
Ah, sorry. Sigma two prime.
How can we see that player two has a
strictly profitable
deviation? Yeah? Considering that
currently the sigma two doesn't actually
allow the utility to be minimized,
there's some other sigma two prime that
actually achieves the minimum. That
sigma two can be replaced with Exactly
right. Let's choose a sigma two prime
that achieves this minimum.
Then the value of this is going to be
strictly smaller than the value of this,
but remember we're talking about player
two.
So, that means player two has a
deviation to sigma two prime
that makes their loss strictly smaller
than their loss here, and that means
player two profits.
Okay. So, let me stop there. This is one
of these proofs where I think you're
reading the textbook and it's like two
lines, but unless you go over it really
really slowly and carefully yourself,
you're never going to understand it.
Yeah.
Just to clarify, are you essentially
saying that then W2 like will switch to
the case where you're in the in the like
in the worst case, player two will
switch to whatever strategy such that
you're in the second case
No, it's not the case that we're going
to immediately get an equilibrium if
player two deviates. What's tricky is
that
here it it could be that given because
player one is not playing a security
strategy, player one might be doing
something really weird here.
And it could be that given this really
weird play by player one, the best thing
for player two is actually something
else really weird. So, it doesn't
necessarily mean that when player two
deviates we're going to get an
equilibrium.
This is not necessarily a security
strategy for player two. Because it's
the strategy that does best against
sigma one, which could be something
really really strange and and therefore
it's not necessarily a security
strategy.
Okay, good. Yes, so good.
Is it pretty clean?
I don't know. What do you mean by clean?
Yeah. I'm just like cuz this is proof by
contradiction. Oh, I see. Um yeah, I
mean you can I think I went for the
shortest possible proof. I mean,
whenever you have a proof by
contradiction, you can always kind of
undo it. I mean, here everything's
finite, so there's not
Okay, there's these like math philosophy
things about proofs by contradiction,
but but here I think you can just pretty
easily convert it to a quote unquote
direct proof. Yeah.
Okay. So, this has been kind of math
heavy. Let me end the last four minutes
with
um
a maybe more sort of
fun application of this. So, in the past
I went through a really simple game that
we could solve exactly. Here I want to
go through a more realistic game
and just show you what the answer is
cuz I think it's a nice demonstration
of the power of of the theory.
So, poker is too hard to solve
full poker. So, we're going to look at a
really simplified version of poker that
von Neumann actually came up with that's
called von Neumann poker.
And here's how it works.
Player one
is going to get a hand.
So, P1 gets a hand
which is just a number X between zero
and one.
Where higher numbers are good. So,
instead of thinking of an actual deck of
cards, player one is dealt some hand
a number between zero and one and let's
say it's uniformly distributed.
Player two is dealt a hand
Y
that's also in zero one.
And then they're each going to ante
$1.
So, each player puts $1 in the pot.
And then we're going to play a very
simplified version of poker where player
one chooses whether to
bet
or check.
Checking means not betting.
Betting means betting and there's only
one amount they can bet. So, the bet
size is going to be B.
And that's some fixed number. It could
be one, it could be two, it's just a
fixed number.
Now, if player one bets, then player two
can either call
or fold.
Really simple version of poker.
And then what happens? Well, if player
one checks, then
whoever has the higher hand wins the
pot.
So, I'll just write it's a little vague
plus one minus one. And this means if I
check, we just compare our hands and the
higher hand gets one and the lower hand
loses one.
If player one bets and player two folds,
well player one automatically wins.
So, player one gets a payoff of one.
Right?
And then down here if player one bets
and player two calls, now each person
has put one their ante plus their bet B
into the pot.
And the person with the higher hand wins
that and the person with the lower hand
loses that. So, I'll write down here
plus one B plus one.
So, when I write plus minus one, it
means the the payoffs depend on who has
the higher hand. If player one has the
higher hand, they win their ante or
really they win the other player's ante
and the other player's bet.
If they have the lower hand, then they
lose their own ante and their own bet,
so they get minus, right?
And the question is
how should you play and who has the
advantage in this game? Here I'm
assuming risk neutrality.
So,
let's say the value of the game
and how to play.
So, when I ask the value of the game,
let me start with the more informal
question, it's who has the advantage?
And I can formalize that by asking is
the value of this game positive or
negative?
Right? So, who has the advantage is the
vague question.
The mathematically precise question is
what is the value of this zero sum game?
How to play? This is a vague question.
The mathematically precise thing is what
are the security strategies for the two
players?
So, you can see how the theory we
presented today gives a formalization of
these very of these vague concepts.
And
we're running out of time, so maybe I'll
put this on the problem set to
to it, but just maybe final thoughts,
who would you Would you rather be player
one or player two in this game? I think
it's uh
not at all clear.
Any thoughts?
Yeah? I'd rather be player one.
Why?
Because like then I get to like set the
rules of the game, right? Cuz I'm
setting the betting now and I
Um yeah, so here the bet is exogenous.
You can't control the size of the bet,
but you do control whether you bet,
right? So that And you actually right.
In this case it is going to be player
one who has an advantage, but the reason
is actually this strange thing here that
if player one checks, player two doesn't
have the right to bet.
In normal poker player two can then bet
after a check, and in standard poker you
actually have an advantage generally
going second and going later. Here
player one actually has an advantage. So
it turns out the value is greater than
zero, and
the how to play, I'll just say sort of
the punchline is that it turns out
player one sometimes bluffs.
Meaning player one sometimes bets even
when their hand is really, really bad.
And I think before this people thought
poker is this psychological game,
bluffing is this thing that's beyond
mathematical reasoning, and it turns out
just just a minimax theorem immediately
explains why bluffing is sometimes a
good thing to do. But I'll put this on
the problem set for you to work out.